and here we go in five four three two
one
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are gonna be talking about the future
of food we're gonna be talking about
biotechnology we have with us today Jack
Bobo thanks for coming on to the show
sure I'm really excited to be here
really appreciate you coming on you are
the chief communications officer at in
tracks on and the senior vice president
you've also that's been three years yes
and also for 13 years you're the senior
advisor of global food policy at the US
Department of State that's correct which
is pretty long time to spend doing
global food advising well it there was a
lot happening into that 13 years yeah
and we got to sustainably and
nutritiously feed the world and that's
crucial it is and the population is just
continuing to grow yo yo and we were
fortunately enough introduced by was it
initially was it
I know RJ and then in tracks on I can't
remember who are no dubs hillerich
connection was yeah but we met in DC for
the first time right well you and I met
here in San Francisco when I knocked on
the door at the science comedy session
that you guys were doing and that was on
astrophysics that's right
with exoplanets with Jesse Christianson
that's when we first hope and we're Sun
when an alien he did when an alien yeah
in his room so that's where we first met
and then met again in DC you and you
were definitely teaching you a lot about
biotech and now we're here again awesome
and you're based in DC I am okay so this
is intense we're figuring out how to
feed and sustainably nutritiously the
whole world but in in tracks on that has
a bigger you know biotech everywhere go
let's maybe do some of that and then
we'll go
into the future foodstuffs oh you guys
are up to everything in biotech I mean
we're talking food we're talking health
healthcare like things like oncology
things like just genetic engineering in
general things like eradication of
mosquitoes the browning enzyme in all
the apples and food this is in very
interesting stuff so teach us about this
yeah well we are DNA calm right so we we
are the ultimate biotechnology company
and I often tell people in trucks on
it's the coolest company you've never
heard of because we're working in health
energy food environment pretty much
every sector now a lot of companies say
biotechnology is a platform that we use
but when you look at what they do it
turns out well they're a health care
company or they're an agriculture
company but in tracks on is really
unique in that we cut across all of
those fields and what we learn in one
really helps us to advance in another
yep and so you mentioned in the health
area well you know we have a couple of
dozen partners that we're working with
on human gene therapy and all sorts of
products that are in cancer therapy skin
diseases eye diseases and we're helping
other companies to bring these change in
therapies to market one of the things I
think is cool is that we believe that
every gene therapy in the world should
come with an off switch if there's a
problem you want to turn it off if you
cure the cancer you want to turn it off
you don't want to be getting chemo for
the rest of your life after it's gone so
that's the thing that in tracks on
brings to a lot of those partnerships
and this is so interesting to have these
22,000 human genes and be able to just
turn on or off the expressions at at
will right so you you know gene therapy
is a very powerful technology but it's
also a very powerful technology and if
it works well that's fantastic but you
know you're over producing an enzyme
that could have an impact on the body
and we're able to turn that off and then
we can turn it on 20 percent 50
percent 95 yeah and get it just right to
dose the patient with gene therapy and
this isn't the drug this is the therapy
itself and how do we get into the cell
and figure out how to do that well so
there are different ways of doing gene
therapy a lot of the companies are using
a viral approach or is a non viral
approach and one of the benefits of that
is that rather than having to send it
out to a centralized facility that could
take 30 days we can transfer those cells
right next to the patient and within a
couple of days we can actually
reintroduce those into the patient and
so the idea is one that it's faster we
hope that it will be more cost effective
and you'll be able to get that benefit
and these are often terminally ill
patients and so you know speed and time
is really of the essence and so right
now the technologies are you can take
the cell out reprogram put back in or
you can deliver nanoparticles into the
cell and have it changed like CRISPR
right so well so and and you know it's a
it's somewhat similar you know you're
using a different kind of gene editing
tool in order to do this but you know
ultimately yeah we're introducing those
changes into the cell but then they turn
off and and so you don't have to worry
about it once you've achieved your goal
this is everything from eradication of
disease to augmentations in humans this
is exciting
well you know we're focused on
addressing diseases you know that are
out there there there are plenty of
challenges that we face right now yeah
okay and then so that's like this health
and then you said energy and agriculture
and you know what else you said was
interesting was that what you're
learning across sectors it's applicable
to each other because it's a biology
it's the code of life right so one of
the things that we're doing is we we
produced the genetically engineer
mosquitoes that are going after the
mosquitoes that carry Zika dengue
chikungunya yellow fever things like
that the enough the eight is at jeopardy
mosquito and this kills millions of
people a year right well so eight is a
[ __ ] D impacts about 400 million people a
year but not as many people are dying
from it more people die from malaria
than from from dengue or for these other
diseases but you know they're obviously
traumatic and dramatic impact and as we
saw with Zika obviously you had
thousands of children that were born
with microcephaly and other disabilities
as a result of that and so if we can
eliminate the mosquito we have an
opportunity to have an impact on disease
have we done oh just curious have we've
done a simulation on what it will be
like to eradicate mosquito from our
ecosystem so so that's a really good
question and so our goal is not
eradication our goal is elimination in a
geographic area now if somebody wanted
to eliminate the mosquito one could do
that but you'd have to actually work
pretty hard and so a couple things to
keep in mind one eighty is a [ __ ] D is an
invasive species pretty much everywhere
in the world so if we eliminate it from
North and South America that's fine it
originates in a part of Africa near
Egypt from hence its name so so it's not
going to impact in fact you're going
back to a more natural ecosystem the
second thing to think about is that
endangered species that might be eating
the insects right we know we don't want
to have an impact even if they shouldn't
be eating it because it's invasive it
still could have an impact well ATS
aegypti is an urban mosquito it loves to
live around people it can't survive on
anything else so it's not out in the
forest it's not you know around the
water it's gonna be wherever people are
and so you don't have a lot of
endangered species living inside
people's homes living in their backyards
and so because of that you're also not
likely to have that you know mosquitos
ATS only flies about one or two hundred
yards and its life time so again you
know if you're protecting a particular
area from the mosquito you know you're
just protecting that area and they're
not going to come back that quickly so
if you really wanted to eliminate it
from a country though you'd have to have
a countrywide elimination program and
you'd have to do it intentionally
now screwworm is an example of an insect
that was entirely eliminated from north
america using sterile insect approaches
that was using irradiation and not
genetic engineering but it has been
demonstrated on a continent-wide scale
to be effective and so the only
difference between what they did with
mutagenesis and what we do is we don't
need a gamma resource and then is the
process for taking away the Zika and
dengue and the other disease is it via
genetic engineering it's the it's the
male mosquito that's being engineered
well so it's both the male and the
female are engineered we release male
mosquitoes male mosquitoes don't bite
and so every mosquito that's ever bit
was a female and so we introduced two
genetic traits into it
one is that self-limiting trait which is
just a lethal trait so when they go out
to the wild and they mate the offspring
all die
another one is a color marker gene
though and what that does is it allows
us to track and trace where our
mosquitoes go oh so we the mark yeah so
we think about with insecticides you go
out and you spray and then you go and
collect mosquito eggs the next week and
the number goes down well is that
because you spray it or because it was
dry the number goes up does that mean
you didn't do a good job or doesn't mean
the weather change right so it's really
hard to know whether or not we're being
effective with no insecticide but
because we know how many we release and
we know the percentage that we collect
which ones are ours and which ones are
not we can actually estimate the number
of mosquitoes that are in the
environment and how good a job we're
doing week to week so we actually know
once we get more than 50 percent control
in those traps that we are on the way to
you know eliminating the mosquitoes in
that area so it's a really exciting tool
that allows us to demonstrate the
benefit of what we're doing and in our
trials we've reduced by 90 to 99 percent
the number of mosquitoes in an area and
we've achieved comparable numbers down
in Brazil where we're commercially
releasing the product today it's
commercially released in Brazil yeah Wow
yeah okay this is exciting okay and then
now how about we do maybe a little bit
of energy on our way to the sugar as
well yeah so in in tracks on actually
our energy facility is in South San
Francisco so not too far from where we
right now and there we're using meth
Anna trove which are bacteria that
naturally consume methane and we've
engineered them to then produce
different chemicals that are basically
the constituents of gasoline and spandex
and other high-value products and so
when you think about biofuels you're
often thinking of taking sugar and
turning it into gasoline well there
you're taking a high-energy form of
carbon and you're turning it into a
lower energy we're taking a low energy
form and we're turning into a higher
value product and so we're also taking
the cheapest form of carbon methane and
turning into a very valuable product and
so because of that you know you actually
get energy benefits from that you have
reduced greenhouse gas emissions from
the fuel that you produce over what you
would have with just a natural oil
source and so you know it's just very
exciting and you think about this the
biofuels replacement market is an eighty
billion dollar market and so you know
that alone is a huge market and so we're
excited about what we're able to do on
that energy front as well so what is
vana Tros vana truesmith an enormous
thanatos and methane at Rose takes
methane from the air well so they're
there they're the organisms that you
know might naturally grow in a high
methane area near vents and other things
and so what we're doing is we're we're
engineering them to produce something so
they're already consuming methane as
their source of food but now we're
engineering them to produce something
with all of that method with all the
methane yeah so interesting what tapping
into DNA can do yeah absolutely and
widespread across all these different
fields well and so if you think about it
if we could reduce the carbon footprint
of the fuel that we produce by 5 or 10
or 15 percent yeah and drive exactly the
same that we are today yeah you know
that that's a pretty dramatic impact
when you talk about you know changing
fuel mileage you know you're not you're
gonna get a few percentage increase but
you've got to produce millions of cars
in order to do that here you're using
exactly the same infrastructure we
already have
mm-hmm okay so this is these are really
good foundational pillars of what you
guys are working on and now this massive
one which is food yeah sustainably
nutritiously feeding earth by 2050 and
through amazing things like these Arctic
apples let's unpack this and where it's
all going
you were just having an impossible
burger - yeah just go just visiting
their facilities and giving it a try for
the first time so I'm really excited
about what we're doing in food and AG I
come from an Ag background working at
the US Department of State in food
policy and there are so many things I
mean one is that one of our subsidiaries
is trans ova genetics which is one of
the largest livestock genetics companies
in the United States and every day
they're improving the genetics of those
animals but they're also thinking about
how do we not just improve a little bit
every year but how do we really expand
that so think about livestock genetics
today what they do is you probably know
there's artificial insemination and they
get the the semen from the bull and they
go out and they use that well that's
like it's brutal it's brutal I mean it's
cow and and birth and then cow and birth
and well there there is a lot going on
there but stripping it away from the
mother well but with the the you know
with the semen you know they're going
out there and collecting it and you know
the see monstrosity that well but but
think about this if this is like a
farmer goes into the seed shop instead
of buying seed he can only buy pollen
that's what artificial insemination is
we're getting half the genetic potential
and so we our genetic gain is half as
fast as it is with plants because we're
only using the semen from the bull and
so part of our thing is well how do we
bring the genetics of the female and the
male so that we can double the speed at
which we improve animal genetics yeah
and so those are some of the things that
we're thinking about is you know not
just how to improve it you know
incremental e which we are but how to
accelerate that and because of the
challenges we have it's important and I
want to say that this is an important
thing to say because I think a lot of
people think like oh is this you know is
this ethical we've been doing genetic
engineering forever for with our food
we've been figuring out what how to
maximally gain yields from our crops
that we plant we've been figuring out
breeding we find partners that we think
have a high intelligence or high
attraction and then we breed with them
so we've been doing these genetic
engineering forever so it's not this
isn't anything new or different but it
but it is it's an extension doing so you
know people are all familiar with corn
but of course you know if we were to
look at Thao sente the progenitor of
corn you know it's a little weed about
this big and it's not very fun because
you know it's got these hard shells and
so through just conventional breeding
and selecting different varieties we
have turned that into an ear of corn
which is like this and which is a hybrid
and so so yeah I mean it's amazing
what's been done just through
conventional breeding and what the
potential is because the problems are so
big we need a really big tool set so one
of the things that you mentioned though
was the Arctic Apple and that's produced
by our subsidiary Okanagan specialty
fruits and for me this is the most
exciting GMO in the world because this
is the first GMO that people will buy
because it's a GMO rather than in spite
of the fact yeah alright so for me
they're buying it because the science
you know it's like this does something
that benefits me as a consumer but
what's exciting about it as well is that
every person who touches that apple in
the supply chain benefits if you're a
grower or less finger bruising if you're
a shipper less loss if you're a retailer
less loss and then the consumer of
course the kids eat it and don't throw
it away at the end of the day yeah and
what people sometimes don't recognize is
that apples are the third most wasted
food item in America bread potatoes
apples so this is not a small part of
the problem this is a big part of the
problem yeah
and so sometimes people will say well I
eat the brown apples my response is well
when was the last time you went to the
grocery store and you picked a brown
Apple to take home because at the end of
the day those are all gonna get thrown
away yeah unless they're arctic apples
and then tomorrow they're gonna look
just fine
- mm-hmm and so what is the engineering
process for removing the browning enzyme
so so there we're just using RNA
interference we're just turning it off
by binding with another piece of RNA
there are other ways you can do it using
knockouts and gene editing and things
like that but our technology you know we
developed this you know a decade ago and
so before CRISPR and other things came
along but all we're really doing is
we're turning off the enzyme that
produces polyphenol oxidase which is the
enzyme that causes browning sometimes
people say well it is browning important
and it's only important if you're if the
seed is going to rot and then grow into
a tree but nobody grows apple trees from
apple seeds because we don't know
pollinated them right so we don't know
how to what tree it would grow into so
most pretty much all trees whatever
variety they are are grown from cuttings
from another tree so they're all clones
of each other anyway mm-hmm and so
nobody's growing it from a seed so you
don't need any of these apples to do to
rot and so rotting has no value for
people it just increases food waste and
you know we lose so much of it
and now it takes rather than a like a
day or even a couple hours to brown now
how long does it last for well it's not
gonna brown even in like two weeks it's
not gonna Brown yeah so now it's gonna
dry out and it's not gonna be as nice
and so so yeah so there are things about
it that you know you might not like as
much but the the Apple itself is not
going to turn brown now we right now on
Amazon you can go and you can buy our
app bits which are dried apples and the
nice thing about those you don't need
any preservatives because you know we
don't have that problem with browning
yeah and so you know it's and we can do
that with the apples are a little too
big or too small that you know aren't
right for selling as sliced apples we
can still turn them into a high-value
product awesome and now this is
extending because you said it by most
wasted food in the US it's bread potato
apple so that's huge we're right up
there in the top most wasted food so
that's already come in hopefully we can
do something about bread and potato
potato there already is - so Simplot has
developed a non browning potato which is
on the market as well yeah
non browning potato potato so I mean
they last pretty long but they do but
but that still causes you know a
significant amount of the the waste with
potatoes and when you when you're put
them in cold storage and those can
become black spots and then people end
up cutting them out and instead you know
they won't have that and so it'll last
longer you'll have a better
higher-quality product and then and then
okay so now we did Apple we did potato
but you guys are also doing I saw alpha
kado and pear and lettuce
yeah so we've got other products that
are in the pipeline and so you know
people sometimes ask you know why didn't
Rex on buy an Apple Company and the
answer is we didn't we bought the
ability to transform every fruit and
vegetable in the world yes we're gonna
demonstrate consumer acceptance that we
can deliver a product that people want
in love but then all of these other
products can come along and so it's a
platform the Apple is a platform just
like biotechnology is a platform yes and
then what else are you working on in the
future food well what else are you super
excited about actually you guys are in
aquaculture too right yeah so one of our
majority owned subsidiary is AquaBounty
and that's the salmon that reaches
normal size in half the time and this is
exciting because when you think about
feeding the world you know we need to
double food production by
year 2050 well if we replaced all of the
farmed Atlantic salmon being produced
today with AquaBounty salmon we would
double production tomorrow and how does
the how does your technology work so
what we've done is we've introduced a
gene that is a growth promoter and the
Atlantic salmon only grows part of the
year and so by adding that promoter it
grows all year round just like a Pacific
salmon and so it reaches normal size in
less time but importantly on less feed
as well yeah so 50 or 20% so think about
that if you're getting twice as much
food and 20% less feed you know that's
that's pretty significant and when you
think about you know the fact that 80 or
90% of all the agricultural land in
America is for food crops for animals
not for people
that's crazy begin to understand the
impact of animal feed on your food
system and it always so strange to me
why we there's more more technology one
of our friends working on where it just
you know just a nice little fence just
moves along you know one foot every
couple of hours a couple of days and
just they can move the animals right on
the grass pasture and those animals will
just move and continue eating the grass
and then they're confined grass-fed and
it's just these things make more sense
than growing all this corn and soy and
then pumping that into animal in animal
feed well you know that there there's a
time and a place for grass-fed but you
know what we couldn't produce as many
animals we I mean do today if we tried
to do it all grass in chickens per hour
in the US yeah so you know that's you
know they're about nine billion animals
that are produced in order to feed you
know 7 billion people so her per year
nine billion animals right first seven
billion human seven billion human the
out oh my god per year just slaughtered
so so the numbers are great but if you
look at how much more productive each of
those animals is today than it was 30 or
40 years ago you know you need three
times as
animals if they were just as productive
as they had been so right so we always
there's this tendency to look at
agriculture as it is today instead of
where we've come from yeah so it's
absolutely true that there is nothing we
do that has a bigger more negative
impact on the planet than agriculture
but there's nothing more critical for a
daily survival and so when you think
about how much water does it take to
produce a kilogram of beef 10 to 15,000
liters of water that's a lot of water
when you think about nothing all that
goes into the feeding and so the grains
and other things but in the grass fed
less yeah well but in 1980 it took 20 to
30 thousand liters of water
less efficient over 50 percent less
water to produce that kilogram so so
things are much better than they were
but we have this tendency just to look
at eutrophication of waterways and all
of those problems and those are all real
problems but there's a big difference
between things are bad and could be
getting worse then things are better but
need to get better even faster I really
like that perspective I think we
frequently lack that perspective Jack I
mean that's probably one of the most
interesting things that you just
highlighted is that when we look at
where we are today one of the things we
have to understand is where we came from
and how much hard work and engineering
that we did in order to make things more
effective and more efficient and
decrease suffering and increase amount
of food and prosperity and then where
are we going in the future
and how do we engineer better world
tomorrow I love that and so when you
think about it you know if you look at
you know agriculture is a problem to be
solved then farmers of the problem but
if you look at where we've come from and
where we're going there the solution to
the problem and I think we need starters
to be part of the solution not the
problem and so that you know we really
need to change that mindset in some ways
you know consumers have never cared more
nor known less how their food is
produced
and you know it they care a lot about it
but they don't have a good connection to
it anymore because more and more of us
live in cities right you know we don't
spend time out in rural places if you
ask people how much do you think you
know about how food is produced people
in cities tend to report higher
knowledge than people in rural
communities that's so funny that's a
great example of dunning-kruger actually
in the cities they think they know more
and then the world they're like we know
a lot but we know nothing right that's
so funny
yeah Wow okay so so continue us on this
on this trajectory where we're heading
with future food yeah so we need between
70 and a hundred percent more food by
2050 because we're gonna have nine nine
and a half maybe ten billion people on
the planet and people are rightly
concerned about how we're gonna
sustainably feed those people but let me
give you a different suggestion now
imagine for a moment that our
productivity increased fast enough that
we did sustainably feed those people so
that we don't need to cut down our
forests and drain our rivers lakes and
aquifers okay so we've got this
trajectory going up and population going
up but what happens to population growth
after 2050 Oh flatlines it flatlines
Yeah right population stabilization yeah
developed nations and equal birthrate
right so for the first time in human
history after 2050 we won't need more
food mm-hmm so if productivity continued
though on that line for the first time
in human history we can take all of that
productivity gains and start to reduce
the footprint of agriculture so by the
year 2100 we could either produce
everything organically or we could take
all of South America out of production
we have choices in a way that we don't
today and so one of the things that I
like to tell people is that the next 35
years are not just the most important 35
years there have ever been in the
history of Agriculture and they are
they're the most important 35 years
there will ever be in the history of
Agriculture if we get it right we're
good forever yeah and so for me that's
really a message of
hope but it's an it tells us now is
really really important and these
decisions that we're making are critical
to the survival of the planet you are so
right about that and it's so interesting
that we were just talking about the
importance of these next couple of
decades in terms of artificial
intelligence as well but we've got to
figure our [ __ ] out so that we get past
these next couple of decades
successfully in the same things true by
agriculture feeding our planet these
next couple of decades most important so
it's interesting how exponential
technologies are impacting the way that
we live and the way that we're about to
be living well one thing that I think
for me changes how I think about all of
this is if you think about the Year 2300
and I asked people how many people do
you think are gonna be in on the planet
and 2,300 if we have 11 billion people
on the planet in 2100 and they say 11 12
15 billion behind maybe yeah three and a
half that's the current estimates
because we will continue having only one
offspring per couple and yeah so so if
if the rest of the world followed
Germany's example of 1.75 children per
person yeah there would be nobody on the
planet and 2,300 if we adopted that is
that right yeah well where where are
they going to come from once you get
below that it's just one and a half
it'll be out by 2300 because you need
over to you count for some people that
die so you need like cold to line people
that just die right yeah so you need
like 2.1 2.2 is replacement so they're
way below replacement rate and so you
know you look at Germany you look at
Japan you look at Italy you look at all
of Europe and if it weren't for your
gracious will no yeah and without
immigration you know all of these
countries would be you know shrinking
look at the biennial is in the Jemez
years I mean they're not having
offspring until they're 35 they're
waiting as long as possible and even
then you're having one kid at most and
they like option they like choice and
also
you know your kids now like they're like
I'm gonna live until I'm 100 I don't
need to have kids when I'm 25 I ain't on
40 freezing sperm sperm and eggs and
gestation now happening outside of the
womb there's all these genetic
engineering disease I mean this is such
an interesting topic about population
stabilization and even I'm fine yeah
well and the sweetest statistician Hans
Rosling who died what he said was the
year 2014 was the year of peak child the
number of children born in 2014 was the
most children that will ever be born in
a given year throughout human history
downhill already so what year do you
think the rate of population growth
peaked what year would you guess was the
year at which it peaked not the number
of people but just how fast it was grown
well I know that we went up by a billion
people about every 10 years recently
yeah 12 right but that's not the rate so
the fastest rate of growth was in 1966
so every year since 1966 the population
has grown but it's growing in a slower
and slower rate and so you know this
isn't like you know hypothetical you
know yes maybe things will start to
decline we've got 60 years of really
good evidence that population rate of
growth is on the decline everywhere in
the world you know the in the developing
world you know sure they're having seven
or eight kids but even today it's only
about two and a half is the the you know
the number of average for the whole
planet and once the in developing world
becomes developed right yeah
and you know so the act that global
total fertility is about two and a half
today and in 1950 though it was five and
so I'm you know things have changed
dramatically you know so now they're
just a couple of countries in the world
that are gonna drive population growth
into the future countries like Ethiopia
Nigeria yeah yeah yeah so okay so let's
that was this really important that we
talked about population demography we
don't talk about that
enough so okay now take us through
because there's a there's a couple of
these exploding industries you know I
mentor at Indy bio and so I get to talk
a lot to all these different biotech
companies that are especially doing
things like growing using stem cells to
grow meat instead of slaughtering
animals so we're you know we're doing
things like taking the stem cell from a
chicken taking it from a coyote from a
pig taking it from fish and just you
know growing and soon the idea is to
have these massive just breweries and
brewed the meat in just bioreactors so
yeah where is that going equal eggs and
yeah yeah so you know you you have sort
of these two protein trends you have the
plant-based foods where the impossible
foods and beyond be Berger and others
that are working on that but then you
have companies like Memphis meats and
finless with seafood and others perfect
day on the the milk that you're talking
about and so so there are different
approaches to this challenge and so
using cells to brew them in a bioreactor
and then provide a substrate in order to
scaffold to then produce that product
you know is something that's that's
coming along there's still a lot of work
to do there's some technical hurdles
that have to get get over but you know
that's likely to be part of the solution
whether it's the in the next five years
you know it's harder to say but you know
10 years from now 20 years from now
indistinguishable tastes well you know
we'll have to see you know it's one
thing to produce a hamburger or our
meatball it's another to produce a
ribeye and a t-bone and you know filet
mignon and all of those different types
and then you have all the different
breeds of you know animals that are out
there so so that's all challenging but
why does cell based meat have to follow
the path right it could it could strike
it's okay to design new things yeah yeah
so you know the they're trying to do
that today because that's that's what
the people wanted in the past but
who knows what people are going to be
open to in the future
hashtag new meat right well you know the
the the sector has sort of looked at the
term clean meat and you know I I think
that there are some challenges with that
term because I think it suggests either
food safety
you know it's safer when you talk about
safety people just think unsafe they
don't think safe or it suggests a moral
and ethical aspect of the conversation
and for me that's unnecessary when
somebody wants to eat a hamburger they
really don't want to have a debate over
the morality of animals and so I threw
out there the concept of craft meat as
an alternative craft meat sell based
food and the reason for that is not so
much that you adopt that specific term
but when you go in and you try to talk
about your product if you talk about
clean meat you immediately get in a
conversation about morality or safety
yeah if you talk about craft you can
talk about quality products brewing
place right this artisinal that we're
the thing that comes to mind when you
think of craft is there is a place where
it was produced in humans made it yeah
right so as soon as you say Memphis
meets San Francisco it's like oh I want
to go there you know it's not a it's not
a package it's a place to produce that
product and so I think what impossible
foods and all of these others is that
they need to be able to connect their
food products to a place because a lot
of where the public is going is wanting
to know the the Providence of the food
they so this is something yeah for just
conspicuous production we want to
conspicuous TRADOC we want to be able to
buy things other people couldn't have
but today we want to know where things
came from we want our purchases to be a
reflection of our values yeah whether
its environmental or ethical or animal
welfare yep and that's the craft food I
like that craft meat craft culture craft
everything it's like you want to know
what farm you got your food from you
want to be able to
say that hey my virtue my value this is
what I believe in and and then you're
right that it kind of strips away from
the morality conversation it's more
about hey that location does it this way
this is what I value okay and we don't
have to pit the new food industries
against the old food industries because
we need twice as much food so impossible
foods and all plant based and cell based
could grow to be just as large as the
current food system and we'd still and
the other ones could still do exactly
what they do today because we need twice
as much and then consumers will make
their decisions right with what they
want and then yeah one of them could end
up thriving yeah yeah so maybe they one
wins out in the marketplace but you know
we've got 50 years before we need to
worry about whether or not that's gonna
happen because we still need so much
more today you know so other thoughts
about future food that you think are
really important to highlight well the
the question for me is not the science
I am totally convinced that science and
technology can get us where we need to
be I'm a science optimist yes but I am a
regulatory pessimist I'm not at all sure
that sign that regulators will allow us
to go there so what was just decided
today in Europe was that European
regulators will regulate gene edited
products exactly like GMOs so unlike the
United States where USDA has indicated
that they're not going to need to
regulate these in plants because the
types of mutation or edits you can
produce are similar to ones that could
have occurred naturally that means that
you know every little product that you
try to produce in Europe needs to go
through a GMO regulatory process or they
have to figure out what that process is
going to be but in theory you know they
are regulated as GMOs and so you know
there's a reason why we don't have you
know every Apple and carrot and tomato
and other
things genetically injured today it's
just there's not a big enough market to
spend a hundred million dollars to bring
it to market on the other hand if you
could just go in and do a simple gene
edit and produce a non browning lettuce
and then you can go through you know for
a couple million dollars get through
regulatory review and have the product
on the market you know you can imagine
doing you know romaine and you know all
these different types of lettuce but
who's gonna spend a hundred million
dollars to bring every type to market so
so there's a real challenge to that
regulatory the other challenge though is
that our food system is fighting itself
you know fighting amongst itself and for
me if everybody would just focus on
solving their own problem and producing
their own product and let the other guy
produce their product if it's a better
product to feel where they'll figure it
out yeah if it's better for the farmer
to grow it in this way then eventually
farmers will figure it out you know
they're pretty smart yep yeah I'm that's
a really important key that you
mentioned regulation because if were
there's got to be the right sort of
amount of regulation to have the right
amount of safety for people longitudinal
testing of all this isolating variables
all this kind of stuff but also let
innovators innovate and if we impede
innovation we fall behind in terms of
around the world the places that want to
innovate so I'm glad that you brought
that up okay this has been super
enriching let's let's ask you a couple
of questions on the way out that we
usually ask our guests Jack do you think
we are alone in the cosmos statistically
I suspect we are not now I feel pretty
confident there are other people out
there yeah and to you what does that
look like well you know I I suspect that
I think less about that than I do about
simulation yeah okay you know for me
that'sthat's the nearer term because if
somebody was going to show up and
introduce them to to us you know
expect they would have done so by now
but I think that the questions around
you know computers and virtual realities
and other things like that that's it
that's a near-term question that we're
gonna have to grapple with as humans
well then let's ask you do you think we
are in a simulation statistically we
must be yeah yeah so you know because at
the rate we're going it seems inevitable
that we won't reach a point at which
it's impossible to determine whether or
not we're in a simulation yeah and once
we reach that moment it's certain that
you know tens or hundreds or thousands
or millions of virtual worlds will be
created yeah well if you've got tens of
millions of virtual worlds which are
indistinguishable from the real one what
are the odds that we're in yeah the real
one yeah that there is a real one mm-hmm
but I I think that you know that
question is interesting but what's
interesting for me is you know the its
implications for what happens to
humanity the next 50 years when we reach
a point where people might be able to
log off log out of the real world
because maybe they they're too old and
then but stay for decades in a virtual
world and will they choose to engage
with the real world and continue to be a
lawyer and make money in order to be
able to buy more virtual cars or will
they just spend the rest of their life
there you know I think that you know
that's one part and then I imagine
another part of humanity will choose not
to do those things
but because of science and technologies
allows them to lead healthier lives you
know it's not as if they're going back
to you know the way things were a
thousand years ago they'll have a very
different engagement with nature because
there will be fewer and fewer people
around nature will become wilder and
wilder after 2050 ah right sounds great
you know today forests are growing in
every developed country in the world
forests are expanding there are only two
countries in the world that are driving
global deforestation you've got Brazil
Indonesia in tonight and soybeans and
palm oil two products interest
and so you know to me you know once we
reach that inflection point you know
there's this opportunity for the
rewilding you know we don't have to try
it's just gonna happen that's so great
that's such an optimistic idea I love
that one because as population decreases
the nature will also increase and and
we're doing things like there was a
billion trees planted in Kazakhstan and
and also things like like you just
mentioned about simulation theory it's
about the expansion of awareness to
these dimensions of thinking and and
when you we do manifest a our own
simulation and we see ourselves then
what do we think or do we learn do we do
where which one do you want to live and
tap in tap out they're indistinguishable
this is I'm glad that you've went into
these deep thoughts about it fascinating
topics alright last question is what do
you think is the most beautiful thing in
the world
Oh for me its connections connections to
people so that's the the best part of
life is getting up and seeing the people
around you and getting to interact with
them every day I love that one
yeah and you got some family you got
some friends you got some co-workers you
got some you know romantic relationships
you got your like business relationships
it's people that you're building the
world future with yeah well because if
you're passionate you need to share that
passion you know it's very hard to be
passionate alone yes
I love it jack very insightful thanks
for teaching us so much about future of
food and about biotechnology this has
been an absolute blast thanks for coming
on to the show thank you this has been
super fun and really educational
so homies people that have been watching
- you guys had a good time definitely go
and share with two other people go and
share some of the knowledge that you've
been learning also join us
subscribe comment below we'd love to
hear your thoughts let's build community
around future food and biotech also join
us on patreon help us support this help
us grow it impact more people thanks
everyone for tuning in thanks Eddie for
filling in our producer director for the
show much appreciated thanks everybody
much love peace awesome all right